we begin tonight with the big news of
the day
earlier president biden held what was
billed as a high-stakes call about 9am
eastern with president xi of china the
topic oh i don't know determining what
role china was playing in backfilling
russia during the war in ukraine for
example with weapons money and oil
it came one week after reports that
russia asked china for military support
and a lot of aid they're running out of
money and one day after chinese and
russian officials had a chance to meet
face to face so while joe biden oddly
decided not to mention this call during
his first appearance of the day he left
it to his press secretary jen saki to
play
cleanup i guess and predictably
unbelievably fashion she made sure to
project biden as
in command
the president spent the vast majority of
the nearly two hours was spent with the
president outlining the views of the
united states and our allies and
partners on this crisis including a
detailed overview of efforts to prevent
and then respond to the invasion and of
course as i was also noted in the
readout but let me just reiterate uh he
also uh conveyed and described the
implications and consequences of china
provides material support to russia
can we possibly not get spin just one
time can we just get the facts it should
be noted that the bite administration
has issued warning after warning to
beijing over ukraine and everything else
and beijing ignored that in fact they
usually come back with sarcastic retorts
now the chinese came away from this
meeting clearly thinking they had the
upper hand
that's not included in the white house
reading it was the alleged chinese
response but the chinese did have a
response late this afternoon shinshaw as
shin shang said which is basically
china's wire service they released a
readout of the biden she call and ed
wong of the new york times summarized it
this way quote it indicates no change in
china's stance she didn't suggest a role
china would play in ending the war and
he used a favorite phrase of his cast of
his of his to cast blame on the u.s
quote
let though who let he who tied the bell
of the tiger on the tiger's neck take it
off so where do things stand right now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else